all right so hello everyone thank you
for joining today's webinar uh we'll be
starting in um five seven more minutes
we are waiting for rest of the
participants to join and meanwhile we
are waiting it would be great if the
participants can introduce yourself in
the chat box you can mention your
education background and research
interest
uh can we hear from the participants
about their educational background and
research interests
um Deepika professor sarkar
hello wrestle it's good to see you back
thank you ma'am
all right we have few participants
introducing themselves
um
so I'm madhu an MSC biotechnology
graduate student and has research
interest in bioinformatics using data
science for genomic data analysis and
data visualization thank you so much
magu for introducing and I'm curious to
know what um what is your motivation to
learn more about biomedical data science
in our
and we also have Brazil with us Brazil
is working as a research assistant at
the genome Center at Joshua University
and is also working as a national
surveillance at covid-19 bypass thank
you so much can you also let us know
what motivated you to learn more about
biomedical data science and art
okay can I tell something because as I
have some problem with typing I'm trying
to switch to mobile I have trying to
switch to laptop from mobile
is it okay if I introduce myself
uh of like voice
he is absolutely professor
okay I am
my area I've done my PhD in computer
science and engineering
currently I'm working with Amit
University Kolkata as like head of
institution Amity Institute of
Information Technology
my primary research areas are
computational social science natural
language processing and machine learning
I have some interest in biological
network analysis along with some big
data analysis so that is a reason that
has actually motivated me to join
today's session
all right thank you so much Professor
sarkar for joining with us and we are
glad to have you uh and participate in
the webinar and I hope uh today's
webinar will be very fruitful for you
for your research as well
and
um what about the rest of the
participants we have
aparna SM Nelson
Savita I'm curious to know about you
guys as well
all right I'm monitoring the chat and I
can see that some of the participants
have started introducing so aparna is
interested in spatial transcript
comments uh can you also let us know
what is your education background and
what motivated you to learn more about
biomedical data science and all
all right uh we have a couple of
responses in the chat
um we have
apron now who's doing PhD in cell and
developmental biology
and then we have uh Nelson
um a student from Philippines and who
wants to learn
foreign
we also have Savita who is a molecular
biologist and is interested in sequence
analysis
and
Deepika says I got to know that I can do
a lot of research with data science
Terrier in biotechnology that we can
analyze the genome data and genome
sequencing and these bioinformatics
skills motivated me to switch my
research interests towards data science
that's pretty motivational thank you so
much Deepika and we have Amir ritas who
is a master student in microbial
biotechnology thank you so much uh Amir
can you also let us know what motivated
you to learn more about data science in
our
[Music]
we have a query from Nelson uh can I
have a certificate for this uh seminar
well this is this is just a webinar
which is part of a program that will
commence soon so for the program after
the completion you will receive a
certificate but not for the webinar
I hope that answered your query
you'll be starting with the program
details in just few more minutes
all right so Amir says he loves to do
some research in this field and develop
information
and Oliver we have Oliver with us who
are the monitor biologists and is
interested in data science using r as
well as Python and he's from USA thank
you so much Oliver so without further
delay let's start with today's webinar
meanwhile the rest of the participants
uh introduce themselves in the chat box
so hello everyone a very warm greeting
to one around my name is Sri gauri
Krishna Kumar and I would like to
welcome you all for the webinar on
biomedical data science in our program
so this webinar is a part of the online
training program that will cover
practical and conceptual aspects of data
science including data wrangling
statistical analysis and machine
learning in application to high
throughput biomedical omics data so
throughout the program students will get
an understanding of the opportunities
and limitations of machine learning in
the context of basic pre-clinical and
clinical research
so before we begin with today's webinar
let me also take a brief moment to
introduce you to the team behind the
program we are a us-based buying Maddox
company who is working with multiple
academic and Commercial collaborators to
develop easy to use analytical tools and
our mission is to make bioinformatics
more accessible
and as a part of our mission our team is
working with local and Regional
coordinators that are helping refine
local program Logistics and adapting
them to the needs of students and
researchers around the world
and this training has to be completed by
over 24 000 participants from 187
countries in over 300 workshops in six
different specialization tracks that
includes oncology infectious diseases
Precision medicine Neuroscience data
science for biomedical data
and as a part of the training you will
have access to the almost logic
resources which takes a combination of
training modules data analysis tools
curated project data effects and
interactive sessions with mentors to
give the students a clear part of the
Bloom's taxonomy pyramid and this also
comes with an access to the omic starter
courses which includes courses on
bioinformatics Precision medicine
multionics that includes genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics and
epigenomics data science that includes
bioinformatics using R and python as
well as cheminformatics and example
projects of different field which you
could learn from and replicate for your
research work
and the almost logic platform also gives
options for analyzing a given data set
and these data sets and Associated
Publications can be used in several ways
that is you can learn by informatics
without any coding at all and for those
interested in opting the norm called
pathway they will be given directions to
access the T by info platform for
bioinformatic processing and Analysis of
data the platform includes demo
pipelines as well as data management and
Analysis Cloud infrastructure to run the
bioinismatic pipeline and different
stages of analysis are performed in
different sections on this multi-ohmits
platform
and for those interested in learning to
analyze data through coding we provide
the omx logic code playground which will
help you develop coding skills while
learning popular packages in our
programming and python to visualize
annotate and analyze complex patterns in
the biological data
so now to view the various courses and
example projects and student projects
you need to first sign up on the
omixological and portal before that let
me walk you through a brief demo on what
a completed profile what a completed
profile on the portal looks like
so once you sign up on the portal these
are the features that you need to update
on your account that is a completed
profile and have a profile image full
name with appropriate capitalization
link to your social media handles a
brief bio about yourself that will
consist of your education background and
research interest and the mentors can
view your progress under the activity
tab the courses you are currently
completing will appear under the core
system finally after the completion of
your coursework the certificates will
appear under the certificate
so with that let us Begin by signing up
on The omics Logical important
I can see that some of the participants
uh have already signed up but for those
of you who are joining us for the very
first time uh I'll show you a brief demo
on how you can sign up
and pasting the link for signing up in
the chat box please with the link and
I'll walk you through on how you can
pick up so for those of you who are
signing up for the very first time you
can click on the create an account
option that you see here
so once you click here you can enter
your name email ID and password and
directly sign up or you also have the
option to sign up using any of your
social media
that is as you can see you can sign up
using your Google account Facebook
account Apple account GitHub account or
even Twitter and for those participants
who already have an account on the
portal you can simply click on the login
now option that you see here and enter
your existing email ID and password and
directly click on sign
so I'll pause for a couple of seconds
for the participants to sign up before
we proceed ahead with the webinar
and once you have signed up please put a
yes in the chat box so that I know I can
proceed ahead
and for those participants who already
have signed up or have signed in they
can put a done in the chat box so that I
know
um I'm good to go
[Music]
thank you
and if you're facing any technical
issues you can let me know in the chat
as well and our team is here and we'll
be happy to look into it
we have one yes
[Music]
and uh if you have any doubts and happy
to
um
show you how you can sign up once again
you can let me know that as well
all right Deepika has also signed up
what about the rest of you I'm
monitoring your responses in the chat
thank you so much you know what I need
all right so I can see that the
participants are signing up so I'll
proceed ahead with uh without further
delaying the webinar but please um keep
sharing your responses in the chat and
if you have anything
all right so I'm going to click on sign
in since I already have an account on
the portal so once you sign up you will
be able to see the courses stamped here
so under the courses tab when you scroll
down below you will see a search bar
that says looking for a specific course
so here if you are to enter the area of
interest that you're interested let's
say the keyword that you're interested
is machine learning so when you enter
that keyword that will show you the
various courses and example projects
that makes use of the concept and when
you type R
that will show you the coding exercise
coding courses that makes use of the r
program
okay thank you so much so you can
navigate through and take a look at it
at your own pace but for now let's move
on to the part where I was explaining
about setting up your profile so for
that you can click on this blue tab that
says welcome back with your email ID
when you click on that that will take
you to your profile set
so here you will see an icon that is
profile this when you click on this it
will enable you to edit the feature that
I was talking about in my presentation
once again as a reminder make sure that
your name is in proper capitalization
add a profile image and your bio should
consist of your education background and
research interest and link your social
media handles as well so once you have
done click on update and that will get
updated on the photo
and you will also see various tabs in
your profile so under the activity tab
like I mentioned the community manager
and the program Mentor will be tracking
your learning progress and under the
courses tab the course that you're
currently taking will be displayed as
well as the progress that you're making
and once you complete a project and
publish it on a portal that will be
displayed under the projects tab finally
when you enroll for the program we
program details and the progress will be
displayed under the program staff and
finally after the completion of the
required coursework and the associated
assignments and quizzes you will be able
to receive the certificates under the
certificates
and another important section that I
want to show you is the project staffs
that is there on the bottom so here you
will be able to check out the various
student projects that have been
published on the portal and these
projects topics range from infectious
disease Precision medicine oncology
machine learning and so on so you can
have a take a look at all of these at
your own pace and that was all about
navigating through the portal so
basically starting with the today's
session I'd like to pass on the stage to
Mr shubham Kumar he will be playing a
short recording
that will consist of the program details
so over to you sugar
thank you
so just let me share my screen
could you confirm if my screen is
visible
I can see the program page
[Music]
foreign
yes
or we are not able to hear it
just a second I'm checking on it
perhaps uh we can pass down to the stage
to miss parshter who can explain more
about the program detail
over to use brush
uh no I guess uh shubham has already
started so we can first continue with
this and then I can uh
explain about the program structure
resources and the registration part
together
yeah thank you
yeah uh can I play the video now
yes please
okay
foreign
it looks like the screen is blank
I don't know
the screen but I don't know why it is
not playing properly uh let just a
second I'll buy something else
okay uh till then uh shubham figure out
the technical glitch I shall take it
over
so uh
okay perfect
so sugar could you please confirm that
if my screen is loading
and if everyone can see it
yes we can see the programs page
perfect
may I suggest something
yeah sure ma'am I hope
if you want to continue your share your
skin I hope you have to suggest him
first open the file then you will you
can share it to your pen I hope that
yeah he is figuring out what exactly is
the problem uh per race uh till then I
can continue with the like program
curriculum and the resources Etc and
then we can pass it over to Sugar thank
you thank you for your suggestion
okay
so um
I'll just quickly uh
open up the program page that is
biomedical
data
signs invites in in R sorry
and here it is
so uh as you like today is the webinar
the free introductory webinar where
we'll be explaining about what we'll be
including in the program what kind of
topics you all will get to learn both
conceptually as well as practical
Hands-On will be there and then the very
first session is on 20th of February
aware we'll be including away of some of
the topics which I'll just show you on
why
so just to give you and program overview
uh that biomedical data science in r in
this program you will learn different
data science skill and experience
bioinformatic methods of analysis and
this training program will cover both
the Practical as well as conceptual
aspects of data science which will
include data wrangling statistical
analysis machine learning in application
to high throughput biomedical omics data
use it bio using big data analysis tools
on the T bioinfo platform
through this particular course you will
have an understanding and you get an
opportunity about the limitations the
perspectives the opportunities in
machine learning in the content of basic
pre-clinical uh and clinical research
related to biomedical data so further
when you scroll down you could see uh
there is a full-fledged curriculum which
is reflecting on the program page and
then there is an interactive session so
on the left hand side or it's maybe it's
your right hand side on my screen there
is a calendar and the first like the
today is the very first like the webinar
of the program and the program is going
to commence from 20th of February I
guess there is some technical glitch
that is why the dates are being
different over here so the first program
the first session of the program is on
20th and that is on Monday next next
week and we'll be rolling out a calendar
invitation to all the particip
participants because the very first
session of the program is free for all
so that they get a glimpse of what is
what we'll be including in the program
and uh they get to know about the topics
which we'll be covering throughout the
program Etc so I'll quickly uh walk you
all through with the curriculum and the
resources which you'll have access to
when
you will enroll in this program not
register in role so the first session
that is on 20th it's the first
introduction to the program where we'll
be covering these all topics that is
Introduction to bioinformatics and data
science what are the publicly available
data repositories so as to extract the
data sets then overview of some key
topics that we'll be covering including
data loading and data preparation data
visualization in art some of the
concepts statistical Concepts and test
t-test Etc Nova and then supervising
supervised machine learning then with
every session and uh these number of
topics which are which we'll be covering
there is some Associated online
resources which are linked so though for
the very first session it is data
processing and visualization loading
data in our bio ml1 introduction to
machine learning in biomedical data and
so on now if we move further the second
session would be on processing High
throughput big data so now the topics
we'll be covering would get like we what
we'll be doing is we will be transiting
each and every participant of our of our
program from a basic level from a
beginner level to an advanced level so
the very first session would be a kind
of a beginner level and then we'll start
transiting each and every student or
participant from beginner to
intermediate and then to advance so now
the complexity of the program will get a
bit more
uh like hi uh so the second session will
be on how to process the high throughput
Big Data
the topics which we'll be covering is
data complexity and need for Preparation
availability and variability of data
unprecedented detail and volume data
heterogeneity complexity and noise then
types of omics data which will include
genomic data transcriptomic data
metagenomic data need for
interpretability and represent a
reproducibility limitations of
statistical analysis Etc and again with
this Associated online resource we have
some Associated online resources which
will include introduction to the
multi-ohmic fields like genomics
transcriptomic metagenomics then bio ml1
High throughput data and technology and
bioml one data preparation for ML
now the third session would be on major
types of machine learning methods where
they where we'll be including
statistical analysis types of machine
learning what is data mining what is
classification then K means clustering
hierarchical clustering supervised
machine learning classification and
unsupervised machine learning clustering
Etc dimensionality reduction then the
next session would be on machine
learning for data visualization there
will be a will get in much deeper way of
tell you about the variance covariance
then what is PCA what is coordinate
analysis what is continuous and ordinal
data what is structured data what are
different patterns and Association Etc
then we have specific sessions on
unsupervised learning for clustering and
then supervised learning for
classification so that every participant
can get a in-depth knowledge of what is
what are the types of machine learning
so in unsupervised learning clustering
we will be guiding you will be telling
you about patterns and learning
clustering for data mining exploratory
analysis on PCA samples feature
components in noise clustering
algorithms and linkage k-means and
hierarchical clustering Big Data
clustering Pam fizzy Etc
clustering samples versus features and
then there will be practical Hands-On
with the Google collab notebooks and
then we have a separate session for
supervised learning classification where
we'll teach you about we'll give you an
overview of what a supervised learning
preparing training and test data sets
what is binary decision trees what is
random Forest discriminant analysis
ldaqda so support Vector machine
validation of model accuracyu working
with our Google collab notebook Etc
so the whole motive of this program is
to like in the end the outcome should be
one can like uh one can prepare their
own independent uh research project how
they can uh use our language and then
analyze the biomedical data which is
being generated from Clinical Research
or pre-clinical research research Etc
so the next session would be on
combining selecting ml methods and the
last would be selecting a project for ML
analysis so this is the outcome which uh
we want every participant to come with
up if they have any idea so most welcome
if not then uh we and the other guides
like the researcher we have a full
researcher or team of researchers so
they'll be guiding you how you can
design your bioinformatics research
project using our our language and which
will include topics like gene expression
transcriptomic or variate analysis you
know mixed microbiome diversity
metagenomics basic research and clinical
depending upon your research interest we
will be integrating our language for the
interpretation part and the data set
would be on different multi-atomic study
it could be on transcriptomic genomic
metagenomic it totally depends upon your
research interest
so
the last part the advanced part is
designing a full-fledged ML and a
project so this is the curriculum which
we'll be covering in a biomedical data
science in our program now if I show you
uh we have few courses which are there
on omic's logic loan portal uhuri could
you please confirm if my screen is still
visible
okay so we can see the introduction to
our program page now it is you can see
the courses page perfect uh so if you
simply write over here R so there are
these two courses which which will uh
like which will appear on your uh home
page on your screen so the first coding
course is uh for the beginners how one
can get started in bioinformatics and R
coding Etc using our coding so when
you'll click over it you can see the
that there are few few lessons there are
four lessons which you'll have access to
once you will enroll in this particular
program and in this lesson you will have
a mix of data or information which will
include a written data which will
include tables which will include videos
Etc so that you can learn in every
aspect so this particular lesson will
provide you will give you an
introduction to analyze analysis of
biological data using our language so in
this coursework you'll get started with
bioinformatics by learning how you can
load data how you can visualize and
process data how you can read DNA
sequences in our DNA replication and
reverse complements in R and in the end
analyze those genomic sequence find
patterns out of it how you can interpret
the language of DNA RNA and protein
so this coursework like is just for the
beginners one who have an urge to learn
to know what exactly is our coding
coursework then uh little bit of if we
increase little bit of complexity then
we have another course that is our
coding course too where we are
introducing the participants with
introduction to data science bio ml so
again the participants will have access
to this particular coursework also when
they'll enroll in this program and in
this coursework we have in total 10
lessons where you will get to know how
you can load data and check for variable
data how you can process data and
visualization what is Advanced Data
visualization then dimensionality
reduction PCA visualization data
visualization using TSN then statistical
analysis test differential gene
expression clustering K means and
hierarchical clustering Etc and further
more lessons are there Advanced
supervised machine learning
classification Etc so this course
basically is designed to introduce an
element of data science in R such as
data wrangling visualization statistical
analysis and machine learning Etc
furthermore to know more about what this
particular courses include how the
information is being distributed how one
can leverage all the resources which we
have on this portal and through this
particular program
I would like now to pass it over to
shubham so that he can play the video
and you will get an idea of how we have
designed the curriculum how we have
designed the courses related to our
language
so shubham I hope now the technical
glitch is a result and you can play the
video
over to YouTube
oh thank you so much
so I'm just sharing my screen
yeah is my screen visible now
yes shubham we can see our screen we can
see the program page
all right so I hope the audio would be
fine so for today I Audible
okay
um
yeah we can see the program page but not
the video which you are playing
yes yes okay please yeah carry on
so for today
is it fine now is the video playing
right
yes please continue
okay all right
um
visualization so uh
picking up the data and understanding
the patterns of the data and why should
we do that why should we pre-process the
data in the machine learning methods are
so Advanced and so intelligent also
smart then what is the necessary to
perform this a data processing so the
need for processing this data is
actually given or discussed in extreme
detail in the bioamel course 7 okay
lesson number three so that is what we
are going to deal with let's let me
share the um foreign
irrespective of the type of models that
you are building either it is more
complex or more simple it's a good model
or a statistically accurate model
mathematically a valid model
if you are going to give the data that
is unprepared or data for example that
is filled with technicalized or data
that is completely inconsistent and data
sometimes it has duplicated information
right so these are not good so following
along what actually constitutes a group
data or rather what actually constitutes
a bad data when you should raise a red
file if you see some patterns in the
data so this these are very important
points that you should keep in mind so
this will not only affect your machine
learning model but it will affect your
and downstream analysis in general so
these types of bad characteristics of
the data that we don't want in any of
our data analysis so for example we
don't want uh signal to noise ratio be
very low so that breaks the question
then how can we estimate this signal
device ratio how can we how can we find
out whether my data has a lower
signature
so we will discuss this in in a short
while and then coming down whether most
of sometimes my um Comics data can
actually have missing data are depending
upon the type of processing that it has
already undergone it can have imputed
data right
um why we are actually dealing with this
because for for data science
applications uh we will mainly discuss
or we will mainly
um deal or we are going to deal with
data that is pre-processed and available
as at a different data possibility
because our idea is to collect as many
data as possible so that that our model
can understand the patterns that is
available in the data so
um in that case when you are collecting
data from different resources or
collecting data that is produced in Mars
there is chance of this some of this
data can be uh uh was not recorded well
obviously is actually missing so we need
to know about how to handle this missing
data and how much of the percentage is
actually acceptable and when the
percentage becomes higher what should we
do about this missing data so we will
discuss that also in in the sessions in
detail but we will quickly go through uh
in the next few minutes also so for
example we might encounter data with the
bachelor that is for example a
consistent difference between samples
because of they are measured in two
different places or the admission by two
different persons Etc and we can we will
definitely for example deal with some
kind of we might deal with the samples
that are in this table because labeling
is done by people and we have to give
some sort of error percentage that can
arise from labeling from a human basis
right so
and these are all some of the uh red
flags or these are all some of the
important points that we want to verify
whether our data has such bad qualities
I mean yes what are we going to do about
that right and this is what is addressed
in explorative data analysis right and
where you can subject your data to a
million of different plotting methods
and visualization tool that is going to
help you each and every one of these
answers whether my data has
whether my data has followed any for
example
any required for data distribution right
many of the statistical methods might
require your data to follow because your
distribution so whether that is actually
part of the map so these are the kind of
answers that you will get when you are
going to work with
um data visualization and exploratory
data analysis and most importantly
sometimes as I mentioned we might have
to uh
resources and also even Within These one
single resource the data might not be in
a format that we want it to be so in
that case how to
um
convert the data into correct format and
what constitutes the format that we
require the data to begin to be used by
Machine learning analysis Etc so these
also they are also very important and by
now you would have guessed that using
data science methods for biomedical data
actually deals with more data
pre-processing rather than applying the
data science method so majority of the
work is done before applying many of
these
um more to be discussed machine learning
tools on your data so the data has to be
prepared when the data has to be
understood very well before subjecting
that to machine learning tools and
methods to answer our type of question
so that is very very important so this I
am going to talk about this for this
lesson here what you are extreme when it
comes to go to this uh this whole lesson
which is very very informative because
uh in the next section we are going to
show you or introduce you to one of the
most used data Security based and data
sets from our bottom which deals with
breast cancer cell line uh Amex data
analysis well this
um why we have seven different types of
molecular compiling then and these
breast cancer cell lines in addition two
uh treatment response data is also
available so you can start as simple as
performing visualization actions to
understand patterns in the data
exploration data analysis and as complex
as using this data for multi-oh mixed
data integration and
um
find out for example at the cell lines
that are going to respond positively to
a given treatment or that selected they
are not responding to training uh even
treatment uh treatments so
um
more about this specific project is
actually given in detail in a in a
separate project
that will be great so where we take this
data and explain you in detail about
what this data is actually telling you
what this paper is actually telling you
and then we use unsupervised and
supervised machine learning methods to
understand patterns in the data and to
help you
get a good introduction to how different
machine and methods can be used to do
answer key questions in uh using data
from property available resources in
this end of this data
foreign
um Most Wanted analysis and the pre
preparation of data then we are going to
go to another Associated resources which
is going to deal with our coding Force 2
and we have made this a lesson three
Advanced Data reservation free for you
to explore me and yeah let me uh go to
that lesson and there's a given in this
important business and here yeah so this
is given free so we can start with
understanding the format of the data
right so you can view the food here so
when I spoke about the requirements of
the data this is what I actually
mentioned so we want the data to be
finding proper uh columns and row
formats so you are you are free to
download this data and open it up in
Excel and and notice generally about
this data this is a curated data set
which is straight away from the cell
line project and that is going to have
approval certain
um
characteristics that we will explore
using
um these data exploratory methods so
what I do first we have to load them to
understand uh to understand the patterns
in the data so the first path is going
to need deal with how to load this data
from your computer into our environment
so if you are an absolute newbie to all
this is where I want you to start this
is already the third lesson in this
course so the first two lessons are
going to have even basic steps on
setting up loading the data and then
verifying whether all parts of the data
is loaded perfectly or not so I want you
all to start there if you are a new
video app and then for example
attaining the data you can notice or you
will definitely notice in this data set
you have some any values or some input
messages data so how are we going to
deal with that so if we have this
incompletions do we share in this
specific data right we are going to
execute them and in the session that
we're going to deal with this specific
lesson then we will discuss about
why excluding these any values is a
better choice than doing anything else
so that's what we will do if you remove
light or keynot you can see that after
performing this the
income
businesses foreign
this and that's going to show uh tell
you about the data distribution in
general right and what do we need to do
for the box plots to look like this and
we have to transform the data into
logarithmic format because the existing
format of the data does not follow a
passive distribution which is absolutely
necessary for majority of the
statistical text and Analysis
uh
so for that case we will simply use a
logarithmic transformation of the scale
of the data and then we can make the box
plot which is going to tell us about the
data for example it's going to tell me
that most of the non-malignant samples
has a median value or meeting expression
value that is little bit higher than the
approximal samples and we can already
see that there is one non-malignant
sample which doesn't fit into the other
four so these are also another clues or
insights that you can generate after
making a box plot so
so this has much necessary or much
needed or codes in this lesson and if
you scroll down it's going to give you
um insights into what you can learn
about scatter plot and how how more
importantly how you can
visualize how you can visualize your
data using static plot and what you can
learn from startup or options like
uh
you can use a histogram right and one of
the most useful
options in this
um in this learn portal is a practice
session sections right and in all the
coding sections and there are other ways
of transforming the data from Lab
transformation you can normalize the
data using Quantum normalization right
so we can discuss that also in the
um for z-score normalization is another
way but uh Quantum normalization and
logs log transformation will
picture of most of the
distribution issues right and yeah most
useful section in this is going to be
practice support section where after you
have learned to for example loot clean
and visualize the data this is the place
section because if we go there then it's
going to take long time and it is also
available in this lesson that we have
given free so feel free to explore and
understand how this transformation is uh
how this transformation is actually
um like that and what are the advantages
of that so I want to show you about this
package code section where it's going to
load a hard console from our server and
you are free to for example a run goes
in this section so for you to get a
clear understanding of what we have
actually discussed so far we have left
of little bits and pieces of these codes
here so so that we can verify what I
have learned in the event sections for
example you just run these codes as it
is it's going to show you another
in this area running code so if you read
it says we have actually made some of
the syntaxes incomplete and please
complete those missing points based on
what you have learned so far so I'm
going to check if there is anything
incomplete in the first
[Music]
line looks like the first line is
actually you complete the separated is
not natural
actually the separator is a creative
format and and most of it as we would
have learned from the level section and
the rest of that section is true okay
let's run this again let's see we can
clear the output of the console by
clicking this and then run it again
and malovich giving me some error so
let's check the other ones okay this
seems to be fine and now okay this part
is incomplete where I have to check the
dimension of the data the data is not
mentioned so let's mention the data and
clear it and then we run it
and then I get the uh
necessary feedback that I have been
successfully running the code and the
answer is Right sometimes you might
encounter for example uh options like
the answer is correct let's see that for
example here
so if I do this uh you can run this it's
going to tell me that is very good okay
I just wanted to show you for example
here let's say that um let's see that if
this is a uh
it is also saying error code
I just wanted to show you but sometimes
if there is no problem in your syntax
it's going to show you success in
running the code but the answer is
incorrect that would mean that you don't
have any syntax error but you have some
error in which in where you are
generating the output so you want to
check your syntaxes and run it again so
that's what I wanted to describe but
looks like I'm not able to do that but
yeah you can actually keep exploring
this I want to stop here due to the
higher concerns but
um this is going to also open up
assignment for you where we have given a
complete console free for you to explore
where you can I took optic bits and
pieces of the code that you have learned
from the previous section and then
create or complete the assignment as you
can see from here and for example if you
come back
and you will have advanced uh
visualization option where you where we
are going to introduce you to alternate
way of visualizing these tools which
will be extremely useful too for example
um
um thank you your visualization to
um to produce publication quality
visualization pattern we have given 30
sections for visualizing this also the
library can get the two with the tool to
run and create an output uh here which
is then download or which you can
visualize whether it's working perfectly
or not that's what I wanted to show you
and with that let me hand this over back
to sigouri and so if you're taking five
minutes extra and if you have any
questions I'll be happy to address of it
here
I will have more detailed questions then
I will be very happy to answer that
during our sessions uh in the program
thank you
[Music]
thank you so much shubham for uh playing
the video
so I guess you all have a rough idea of
what we will be including in the
coursework
and the associated online resources
which are there on the mix logic loan
portal so as to enhance or upscale your
conceptual as well as practical skills
um now I'll just quickly share my screen
once again
so that I can tell you that how you can
enroll in this particular program what
are the resources which you'll have
access to once you will join the program
and then uh what are the available
scholarship
so on the same program page shubham
could you please share the link of the
program page in the chat box on the same
program page when you scroll down when
you scroll a little bit more you could
find three different tenures one is 45
days then is 60 days and then is 90 days
so there are some common resources which
you'll all have access to when you'll
enroll in the program so the common
resources are you will have access to
the online tutorials
then you will have access to the project
example which uh SRI gauri just showed
you
uh while explaining geometry logic learn
portal and the different tabs present in
the portal then third is the coding
sessions so obviously R means codings we
will have access to coding sessions
Google collab notebooks Etc then all the
session recordings virtual uh the
recording recorded version of The
Sessions would be shared with you and in
fact the recordings will be present on
the program page itself so once you'll
enroll in the program those participants
can see the recordings of each session
here below the associated online
resources also so now moving further you
will have access to the online Mentor
support
Online technical support via our
WhatsApp groups because I guess nowadays
WhatsApp is the most visible uh kind of
a group where one can uh you know
clarify their doubts and quickly ping
and uh get across verification of their
queries then the LA the SEC the second
last is the certificate after the
completion of the program and then the
example Cloud pipelines on the T bioinfo
server so by example Cloud pipelines I
mean the data set is being already
uploaded over there and you can
visualize uh the visualize the results
uh how the visualize how the results
look like Etc you cannot interpret your
own data set or you cannot download your
own data set and do the interpretation
further now what is the difference
between the three is in 45 days you all
will go through with the full-fledged
training related to R uh related to the
syllabus and the curriculum which I just
showed you and uh both conceptual as
well as practical then in 60 days you
have two different opportunities one is
the research proposal like you will have
access to the first 45 days would be
devoted to your trading part and the
next 15 days the left 15 days would be
devoted to your uh like how you can
draft your research proposal once your
research proposal is done you can share
your user Proposal with the mentor so as
to get a valuable feedback from him or
her and accordingly you can do the
Amendments you can do the changes and
further complete your uh project the
research project and the second one is
one-on-one Mentor sessions so for
example
uh if you are stuck somewhere and you
cannot join any group Live sessions so
you'll be having access to one-on-one
Mentor sessions also where we can fix
the call of yours with the mentor of
around 20 to 30 minutes and you can
clarify your doubts
in 90 days you would have access to
three different things I would say one
is the project driven Cloud pipelines on
t bioin plus server this is the research
license access which you'll get
one again is the one-on-one Mentor
session and third is the you have 45
days extra to draft your own independent
project so the first 45 days would be
your training and the last 45 days the
second uh the the next 45 days would be
like we'll be guiding you how you can
complete your own independent research
project and come up with a research
publication and if not research
publication if you are interested in
poster presentation in different
research Symposium or International
conferences so this is also one of the
outcome so this is the difference
between the 45 60 and 90 days tenure the
resources which one would have access to
in common and the additional one also
now talking about the pricing part so as
you can see on my screen right now I the
pricing is reflecting in INR for the
Indian for the Asian uh community
so for 45 days it's 7 500 for 60 it's 10
000 and for 90 it's 15 000 and now if
someone who is in us or in maybe a
Nigeria or in any European country so
they can change the currency according
to their currency so for example I'll
just show you for USD the pricing for uh
USA or the Canadian people community is
150 for 45 days then 300 for 60 days
dollars and then dollar 450 for 90 days
and if I uh for the Nigerian Community
or the African one then if you scroll
down you can see here the pricing in
naira as well
uh so for 45 dates it's naira 50 000 for
60 days it's neither one lakh and then
for 90 days it's neither one lakh 50
000. now how one can proceed with the
payment checkout so for example if
someone is interested in 90 days they
can simply click on this buy now button
and uh the omics logic checkout page
would appear
if there is any coupon code available
you can click or you can type the coupon
code here click on apply button you can
see a message popping up that the coupon
code is applied successfully then you
need to fill out the user details your
name your email address your phone your
country occupation organization Etc and
you can and when uh the coupon is
successfully applied you can see the
order summary over here you can see that
the discount coupon has appla applied
and the total would automatically change
once it is done you can click on this
check box and select the payment method
either strike through credit card or
maybe debit card or via PayPal
so this is how uh the payment checkout
is done other than this we have uh other
options also like bank transfer is
available then those who are in India or
in like Asian Community for them we have
the upis also Google pay or uh like
paytm Etc upis are available
and then we have uh different uh pay
then link also if someone is not
eligible or like because of some
currencies issue Etc so we can provide
them with other payment options also now
the last thing which I wanted to discuss
with you all is about the scholarship
opportunities so as you know that the
date is fast approaching and the first
session is next week 20th that is Monday
uh we are giving right now with 20 to 30
scholarship
or I would say up to 50 scholarship to
the uh to our community to a
bioinformatics community and those who
are interested to Avail the scholarship
please drop your email address in the
chat box and our Representatives would
connect with you via email and uh or
maybe a phone call and shigori could you
please also drop uh my credentials my
official credential my contact number
and email address in the chat box so
those who are interested if they can
directly connect with me via WhatsApp or
mail Etc what is the most visible mode
for them to communicate with me they can
do so
and uh please drop your email IDs
whosoever is interested now if anyone is
having any question regarding
registration part the resources the
payment the scholarship anything please
feel free to either unmute or type uh in
the chat box and I'll be there to answer
your questions thank you so much
over to you should worry
thank you so much parish and Shivam so
we'll pick uh pause for a couple of
seconds for the participants to share
their queries
first we have a query from Professor
Hussein he's asking how can I pay from
Bangladesh yes so uh Professor Hussein
uh please do let us know on the given
mail address in which particular tenure
you are interested and we shall provide
you with a payment Link in your
Bangladesh currency and you can proceed
uh
through the link given that will be
providing you
yeah thank you we'll be like we'll be
mailing you and uh like one of our
Representatives would connect with you
regard confirming your tenure Etc and
then we'll provide you with a payment
link and you can proceed further with
the payment checkout process
I hope that answer your question
you're welcome
thank you anyone yeah anyone who's
having any further queries please uh
bring in the chat or please those who
are interested to be a part of the
program and enroll uh please drop your
email address here and we'll be
connecting with you
Sharma mom will you please repeat about
scholarship Shop Halloween
so regarding the scholarship I was
telling that we are offering right now
to everyone up to 50 percent scholarship
so those who are interested they can
ping in the chat box their mail address
and are representative will connect with
you and guide you the steps to Avail the
scholarship accordingly
so
um pallavi please drop your email
address and maybe either shubham or any
other representative would connect with
you and guide you the steps to further
register or for the Avail the
scholarship and enroll for the program
thank you so much pallavi and
Colette is asking you have mentioned
that the scholarship only covers 50
percentage of the food
uh call it uh I guess I haven't
mentioned this right now that uh the
scholarship will only cover 50 of the
fee uh this 50 percent uh off or
discount was give like was active in
January
um till mid of the January and now it's
not active but still we are providing
different participants from different
Community who are facing some financial
problem or we are providing them with 50
scholarship right now also if you're
interested please uh like share your
email address here in the chat box and
uh we will be
guiding you and dealing texting or
mailing you accordingly
sure Hussein please drop your email
address I guess we have your email
address you have already done so please
connect with you
thank you so much uh Professor Hussein
and Colette does anyone else have any
further queries regarding the
registration or the scholarship
if no one has any uh no further queries
we'll be uh ending today's meeting so
before we end the meeting please uh
share your email IDs to receive the
details of the program and the
scholarship form
thank you so much we'll take a note of
it
thank you nuranir and aparna we have
noted your email ID
foreign
[Music]
for joining today's webinar and along
the way if you're having any queries
please feel free to reach out to us
through the email ID that I've provided
in the chat that is marketing at
omicstrologic.com and I've also shared
the contact number I'm re-sharing it
once more so that in case you have
missed you can return
and with that thank you so much and have
a great day
thanks